Oh
hello everyone I'm from your telephone
company introducing the cinemasins
hotline the world's only 24/7 emergency
line for movie mistakes film clubs and
cinema sins you just saw a movie and it
had tons of sins some of them probably
pissed you off worst episode ever now
through the magic of voicemail you can
share your sins with us complete with
your own emphatic and passionate
narration now I remove my finger the
best sins suggestions will find their
way into future videos in both text and
audio form so if you've ever wanted to
contribute to a movie Sene's video or
panel if you just like calling your
favorite youtubers and bitching them out
or giving them really good stock tips
take out your phone and put the
cinemasins hotline on speed dial
write this in second so you're on the
speed dial after 2 days I should also
note that by calling the cinemasins
hotline and recording a message you give
us permission to use your sin your voice
message and probably even own your soul
and the souls of your children just FYI
405 459 sin or 405 four five nine seven
four six six what are you waiting for
call now operators are standing by
well the voicemail system is standing by
pick up the phone and start dialing is
your landlord ready will vicked you good
pick up the phone and start dialing let
the telephone ring for at least a minute
or about ten rings to give the person
you're calling time to answer